Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dylan
from Georgia. Dylan from Georgia.
Welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Dylan from Georgia, you were on, but you've
got to select the correct audio device.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yeah, now I can.
Speaker 2: Cool. Last time I was on, we had
a it sounded like a robot was speaking in,
if you remember that. Well, that.
Speaker 1: Happens with a lot of callers,
I actually.
Speaker 2:
Yeah, well, I've been a member for a
while and it's great to talk to you.
I just had a kind of two questions. The first one
was, I don't know how much research you've done
into it, but what are your thoughts on the Willow
projects being approved in Alaska and kind of how
does that make you feel with the contrast of all
of Joe Biden's promises about, you know, trying to
combat the climate crisis and more electric cars
and tax incentives for electric? When I read that,
I think the Willow Project would produce the
equivalent of 2 million gas powered cars. Yeah. So
I just I don't know how much you read about that.
Speaker 1: So here I have a bunch of articles
bookmarked to read and the insanity on Twitter
this week made it so I didn't get to from the
little I've read so far. I'm very concerned about
it. I want to learn more and maybe next week I'll
do like more of a deep dive segment on it. But I'm
certainly I'm certainly quite concerned about it
from what I'm from the little I've read so far.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. I've it concerned me a lot
too. And I, you know, I've been reading a lot
of I don't know if you know who need higgins's
but he has a, a smaller, smaller YouTube channel
about what he calls, I guess the medic crisis,
which is just this feeling that everybody has
that something is wrong and we don't quite know
how to address it. He does a good job of kind
of consolidating that, but he just mostly talks
about the climate stuff in the sense that. You
know, we need a cultural change, not necessarily
making things more efficient. And even the drive
to try to make things efficient as quickly as we
would need to write in order to combat this stuff
is almost counterproductive because of the things
that we would use to construct all of these green
technologies rely on fossil fuels. And, you know,
it's just it's a cultural shift that we have to
make. And, you know, I guess it starts at the
individual level. You know, I try to cycle, but
that's that's pretty much all I can do at this
point is just cut back as best I can.
Speaker 1: And I'm sure you're like,
you're not you're not flushing your toilet
10 to 15 times, which I'm sure helps.
Speaker 2: You know, I'm I'm trying
you know, I'm at eight right now.
I'm really trying down to five.
Speaker 1: That would be good.
Yeah. If we could only flush only
five times, they'd be better. Yeah,
I just made a note about Nate Hagan's. The content
seems interesting. I'm going to check it out.
Speaker 2: Yeah, Yeah,
definitely. Yeah. Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right, Dylan from
Georgia. Great to hear from you.